ja die militärische situation im osten
der ukraine sie spitzt sich immer mehr
zu für die ukrainische armee wir müssen
uns heute die lage noch einmal in der
region luhansk ansehen das ist die
region ganz im osten des landes bereits
in den letzten monaten hat russland etwa
95 prozent erobert doch jetzt wird hier
dieser letzte kleine letzten kleinen 5
prozent dieser region werden
wahrscheinlich jetzt auch in den
nächsten stunden von der russischen
armee überrannt die großstadt lässig
neben sie werden etwas wir drin haben
ist die letzte großstadt ehemals 100.000
einwohner die von der ukraine noch
gehalten wird doch diese stadt ist fast
umzingelt und wir haben verschiedene
berichte dass sich die ersten
ukrainischen einheiten direkt von dort
auch schon zurückziehen wir haben neue
bilder heute von einer ölraffinerie die
ölraffinerie von investitions sie ist
sozusagen auf halbem weg zwischen dieser
fast eingekesselten stadt und dem
ukrainischen kern land sie wurde von
russischen truppen eingenommen wir haben
hier aufnahmen der staatlichen
russischen propagandisten von ria die
eben in einem schützen fahrzeug der
russischen armee mitfahren und wir sehen
tatsächlich dass diese raffinerie jetzt
unter russische kontrolle zu sein
scheint was auch bedeutet dass die
letzte zufahrtsstrasse nachlässig tanzt
jetzt nicht mehr passierbar ist sondern
zumindest unter voller kontrolle der
russischen armee steht feuer kontrolle
ist das stichwort warum ist russland je
weiter auf dem vormarsch auf grund der
unfassbaren feuerkraft wir sehen hier
ein ebenfalls neues video der russischen
armee wo wir bm 21 grad systeme sehen
jedes von 141 raketen die über 20
kilometer geschossen werden können wir
den
1234 dieser systeme die hier alle stehen
bereit sind zum feiern und jetzt sehen
wir wie diese unfassbare
vernichtungskraft hier losgelassen wird
dieser systeme wie also insgesamt ja
insgesamt 160 raketen mehr als 160
raketen abgeschossen werden auf die
ukrainischen stellungen die den kaum
etwas entgegenzusetzen haben hier sehen
wir auch weiterhin ein weiteres system
was auch hier die front beschießt
diesmal in der region donetsk und auch
hier sehen wir jetzt am ende noch mal
das ein schlag video also könnte man
kurz festhalten und sehen wie in diesem
großen radius hier etwa 40 raketen
einschlagen ukrainische soldaten die da
sind sind eben in höchster gefahr
sozusagen von diesen von diesen
einschlägen auch getroffen zu werden ja
was hat die ukraine den entgegenzusetzen
bislang nicht viel aber das soll sich
jetzt ändern immer mehr waffen treffen
ein so auch endlich die deutsche
panzerhaubitze 2000 und wir sehen hier
erste bilder von ihr und wir können wir
kurz zu gucken im hintergrund ist hier
alles man etwas gehört das heißt es wird
versucht wenn es dort irgendwelche
landschaftlichen symbole gibt eben genau
zeigen wo steht dieser haubitze dann
wird versucht das weg zu wegzuhören weg
zu pixeln sozusagen und das haben wir in
verschiedenen bildern hier auch herrn
pixel auf der munition damit die russen
nicht genau sehen was für eine munition
das ist und auch hier sehen wir das noch
mal ist das ganze sozusagen
schwammig gehalten damit man das nicht
genau sieht wie sie haben auch ein
kurzes video ein sehr kurzes video wo
man hier einen ukrainischen soldaten
gleich sieht und da hinten die
panzerhaubitze 2000 sieben stück aus
deutschland gab es bisher drei weitere
sollen folgen im einsatz
dass also die chance der ukraine und die
hoffnung der ukrainer dass man mit
diesen waffen jetzt doch irgendwas
zurückschlagen kann und den gegner eben
doch zumindest stoppen kann wenn ihr
irgendwann die region nur hans
wahrscheinlich komplett eingenommen hat
wir sehen uns noch mal die situation in
einer nachbarregion archiv nördlich
davon hier sehen wir haben die ukraine
zumindest einen russischen vormarsch
gestoppt zwei
schützenpanzer wurden hier zerstört man
sieht das an diesen braunen das ist also
ausgebrannt und ein dritter
schützenpanzer auf dem steht hier der
soldat und filmt das der wurde also
erobert der wurde nichts zerstört und
wir gehen mal weiter vor und sehen das
zum einen dieser schützenpanzer hier
inklusive munition von den ukrainern
beschlagnahmt wurde und gleich noch ein
weiteres fahrzeug inklusive eines
artilleriegeschütz das was da dran hängt
was auch von den ukrainern hier
beschlagnahmt wurden und wie immer
werden die ukraine natürlich diese
waffen sofort wieder nutzen sie werden
sofort wieder fit gemacht wir sehen uns
hier die die artillerie auf der linken
seite und rechts davon ein sogenanntes
mtl b was diese artillerie zieht und
eben auch truppen transportieren kann
diese waffen werden also von den
ukrainern so schnell wie möglich wieder
einsatzbereit gemacht damit sie im don
bass und an anderen fronten wo es
teilweise sehr kritisch für die ukraine
aus sich derzeit wieder eingesetzt
werden können